ich habe einen dino ich habe stegosaurus
ich habe eine rpg barcelona der nächsten
folge von minecraft galaxy bei mir ist
es die folge 24 würde 22 23 irgendwie so
um den dreh hat was hast du vor dieser
folge ach so hallo herr weitertragen war
leichter einsteigen dann ein kontrast
diesmal wieder dabei ich bin vielleicht
dabei dicht aber nicht zu verfluchen
habe ich mir gedacht ja das möchte mag
ich möchte mal kurz bei dir vorbei
schauen und wenn alles gut klappt ein
bisschen was von haar von die holen und
dann so ist ein voodoo puppen magie
betreiben weil sie es von klippen
stürzen und als möglichen das wird
bestimmt lustig du hast dich ja auf das
ist das alles wird richtig wie hexerei
und dna also zeugs also ich kann
mittlerweile fliegen ohne fledermaus
verwandeln ich habe auch resistance 2
alsdorf perfekt drin also viel schaden
und 22 und das richtig coole kritisch
ist von mir das heißt die flüchten
vorgehen das ist da wird richtig lustig
ich hab jetzt in dieser folge
hoffentlich gleich mal mein eigenes die
noa und dann machen wir ein stärkeres
und der den zehn ich mir dann wird dann
habe ich ein dinosaurier dass das worauf
ich mich erstmal spezialisieren sollte
also auf fossil archäologie die folge
zufällig gesehen von der die letzte ich
habe irgendwann laufen gegen das gezocke
also als schlosser schalters ganz schön
fossilien gesucht und allerdings ob welt
gefunden und hast dann mache ich echt
nicht viele gefunden das war ein
bisschen traurig also wenn du welche
hast dann wäre ich sehr sehr verbunden
werden welche geben würde
ich habe bestimmt über welche rumfliegen
muss man gucken
diese rally sind nicht so selten das ist
sicher so wie diamanten würde ich sagen
also diamanten sind ja auch nicht so
selten wie man wissen nachgeschmissen
petra steps oder zu schwach wurden ja
ich habe auch voll viel ich weiss auch
nicht als fremd waren sagt weißt du ob
ich wollte mir sonne coole abrüstung
machen holt man den russen
ich habe mich gerade bei dir ja ok
wenigsten ja das ist immer so immer am
anfang der folgen bin ich war kurz ein
bisschen bis ich wollte so eine coole
raschen rüstung machen weil ich mir auch
schon diese weapons box gemacht habe und
jetzt ohne ak aber ich weiß nicht wie
ich mir diese richtung machen soll
schau mal ganz genau nach gucken
ich versuche ich habe gerade ein krieg
beschäftigt über mit fröhlichen creeper
ich glaube ich mache meinen blog schrieb
boah ey und mir auf meinem haus ich
wollte ein bisschen rum gehen eigentlich
passt gerettet töten weil ich genommen
braucht und er kommt einfach zu mir ja
ich versuche gerade deshalb hier oben
bieten hast was du entweder so hab ich
freue mich schon verknüpfen
auch deshalb tintenfisch ich guck mal
was ich was ich alles was ich habe von
dino hut ich kann mir neil terex auf den
kopf machen da guckt dass man häufig
werde ich das nochmal muss hart mit ma
was habe ich dann wieder das telefon auf
den kopf wenn man hier so einen turtles
highlight schildkröte viking hat guck
mal ich haben abbruch noch nicht bei mir
aus dem komischen es muss jedoch
aktivieren leider musste allerdings an
denen noch dann klingen afro lawrow
afrika africom ich hab mal froh ist das
geil
das ist ja mal echt cool davon muss ich
jetzt erst mal ein foto machen
das sieht aber echt cool aus wie afro
mitsamt kam auch noch drin
soll ich denn doch rose auf den kopf
cool muss den aufruhr geraten zum ändern
weil ich will nämlich verändert haben
ok hab leider keine brauchst du n appel
damit ich mir in safari nett machen kann
was die uci will das heißt das was ich
wieder benutzen kann dann kann ich mich
mops transportieren diesem poker ball
schnappe saison bot das ist ein kassiert
und dann kann es woanders wieder frei
lassen dann ist es halt wieder benutzbar
kannst du auch mit einfach nur einfach
mal nutzbar finden in verschiedenen
dungeon kisten aber wenn du sie wieder
benutzbar machen willst also wenn er sei
logisch dass wills mit mir einfach
benutzbare sehr billig dann musst du das
länder ferien machen in diamant glaube
ich online crystal meth anders
jedenfalls ja das ist ganz sinnvoll wenn
wenn wenn sich nämlich tiere holen wir
zum beispiel kühe oder sassen steigern
will weil man ja nix wie litzen du zum
beispiel de cuba dir da oben rein
kriegen da brauchst du jahren wieder
rein zu schieben
deswegen zum pokal safari nette mann
geht das wirklich poken einer farinet
argument aber ich nenne pokal weil er im
prinzip das macht das den puck beim ok
cool ich muss ja jetzt gerade ich wollte
einfach gucken was ich hier von meinem
ganze scheiße anpflanzen kann ich wollte
auch gleich mal meinen brocken entfernt
helm reparieren also das ist so ein
fossil hält ich weiß nicht was die
beging aber ich mache das enz sein
schwert ist irgendwie recht nice weil
druml es gibt raclette seinem blitz
wunder kommen damit einschlägt weil sie
nicht ich muss das gleich mal repariert
weil es gibt ja so eine lakic von
christoph beyer hast du schon gesehen
wenn die von dem blitz getroffen wird
dann wie die doppelt so groß und es kann
als sein wenn du beim entscheiden es
schwert dann oder sword einem anschlag
auf masten blitz 100 kommt die kiste
sich dann oder der schweiz weg ist die
verdoppelte richtig gut
als ob uns wäre das werk wieder aus wie
so ein charge creepers so eine charge
kiste halt und die gdl beharrt er
doppelt viel speicherplatz wie normale
ich habe einen dino ich habe stegosaurus
also versetzt den leser aus dass man die
mit den walnuss curtain wall notieren
kann also was wir haben diesen kleinen
dicklich aber sieht die ami habe
deswegen sein erstes steht glaube ich
mir den von von der größe von einer
weile noch so einfällt andino die usa
machen nicht so fertig der ist voll flug
bestimmten tag und benny nach dem namen
am besten beim reiten gibt es in dem
text der ich hab schon eingefunden
aber nun dungeons wie solchen dann nicht
die hier in sondern karneval notiert ich
gebe dir richtig ihr könnt aber in die
kommentare schreiben
wie soll ich meinen ersten stegosaurus
nennen das wäre super
also ich weiß nicht ist das thecus
august ein böser dinosaurier
es gibt ja viele dinosaurier wieder
tricks oder so die sind von anfang an
böse aber es gibt auch so ein paar die
sind erst so wenn du die angreifende
böse und den hier ist erzählt einfach
mal hierhin müsste pflanzenfresser sein
ja habe ich auch gedacht als auch schon
so grün aus wenn er immer zu viele
pflanzen ist ey du ich hab total bock
pokémon zu gucken
irgendwie rum auf einmal weise nicht
wegen dem safari net oder er weiter ich
seitdem die pokal gesagt hab ich mir
gedacht komm wir ab ob man alle staffeln
durch konrad upmann ist aber klar ich
schaue gern an nächste an sich aber
pokémon ist einfach kinder selbst ist
schon sind ja ja das habe ich auch
damals ja das ist aber es ist so dämlich
team rocket und so dauerhaft hässliche
verkleidung inklusive sofort ist leider
richtig dass es schon zuschauer fasst
ja ich hab's früher als kind übels gern
geguckt
ich glaube ich schmeiße jetzt erstmal
meine öfen an und während derzeit mache
ich hey du hast nichts gesehen
ich habe auch nichts gesehen dass ein
bachelor das ist gut
du hast nichts gesehen ich wollte mal
ganz kurz meine ganzen möglich an
schmeißt mit der ganzen scheiße die ich
hier habt war das anders da wollte ich
mir eine rpg wollte überwachen
a ich habe dir gerade herausgezogen und
ich habe krebs bekommen das heißt ich
kann dich jetzt mit wurde um magie
verzaubern
danke tschüss okay was ich jetzt machen
was soll ich machen muss bin ich blöd
ich habe direkt wieder vergessen ich
mache heute ach ja eine rpg
ich hoffe dass wir jetzt so spektakulär
wie es mir vorstelle dass es wird er
auch übermorgen wird in bankaktien rpg
mainz ich dass die meisten role playing
game kenne ja ich mache game einmal
kraft entwickelt sich bei ebenso wie
cool daher das musste ich gestern machen
für mein projekt für die krone spielte
studierst du musst eine dreidimensionale
3d web anwendung machen für einen
browser und wir machen das spiel eine
kugel durch den raum rollt und
verschiedene würfel über rollen kann und
weshalb überrollt dann teil dürfen sich
in kleine würfel und der punktestand
wird erhöht und es ist halt wirklich
komplett einfach nur ein browserspiel
okay das ist die website optischen
vanessa vendor of line height als
projekt wurde halt wenn du es auf deinen
pc gas erst mal an - dafür keinen server
sondern einfach nur dass die anwendung
an sich funktioniert das muss man
abgeben als projekt so an sich an den
tropf dann okay cool
ja ich stehe ja was
ich weiß nicht ob das dauert ein spiel
aber ja marketing management jetzt ab
oktober
ich glaube dass es weniger programmieren
programmieren von fünf morgens bis fast
ich habe eine rpg rabatt so als wollte
er doch rpg patronen weiß was viel
cooler ist ein rpg nix es gibt einiges
zu jan kaetow machen so mag eben werfer
ja ja ist aber dafür muss schweine
diese dubstep der der schweine
verschießt die regenbogen cookson ok
cool also aber ich weiß ich dass die
sache ist halt auch wenn man wenn man
diesen diese dubstep kann hat dann muss
man so was drauf ist eine beschreibung
überschreiben ja wie viel musik von der
und deswegen produzieren hier so oft
oder ich habe wenn man sie mal ganz gut
sitzen gerade deswegen ist ein eleganter
als geholt anlass sondern als nicht ganz
gehört musste nicht mal weiß wirklich
deutlich höheren kann dann muss man
schon den track ja ich glaube länger als
zehn sekunden darf man nicht also
irgendwie ohne regen gab es mal ich weiß
nicht wie das jetzt ist youtube video
wieder abonnenten löschen weil ich es am
6 also denke ich schon etwas mitbekommen
wird mit den abonnenten bis zum 16 juli
juni knallt ist also nach quellen alle
raus die als inaktiv markierten für
youtube und bei großen kanälen die schon
lange weisen könnte hat auch recht viele
sonnen habe ich euch das befürchtet vor
allem weil ich finde es irgendwie cool
dass man nur noch so die aktive hat das
ist einerseits cool aber ich weiß nicht
wie youtube inaktiv definiere ich dich
mal fliegen auch gerne leute weg also
nur als vorwarnung für einige die sich
wundern warum lasst ihr abo gelöscht
wird könnt ihr sogar sein wenn ihr die
folge gerade seht das entfällt dann hat
sich in falscher weise gelöscht einfach
wieder neue klicken und dann geht's
wieder gut dass auch geklärt
ich brauche hast du zwei gunpowder für
mich eventuell gunpowder ich habe
bestimmt eigentlich so umgangen im
moment man muss immer gucken und ich
brauchen suche
zum nikolaus getan deutschrap klinge ich
brauche birken sitzen jede menge
gunpowder ich habe bestimmt gern wirken
setzt legen habe ich gar keine
ja ich musste mir auch erst saniere
gegen mich keiner aber dass du bist auch
ganz toller kriegst du ja nur durch
krieg und kripo laufen hier so selten
warum überlaufen weg vor mir was bei den
seltenen figur ja möchtet ihr kommt
erwartet mal kurz das war's nur weil bei
mir laufen darum eigentlich suchte da
hab ich ganz toll aber ich habe mir nie
wirklich groß aber ich habe zwei stück
im inventar zwei ganze land wurde ich zu
viel meinen kritiker waren sonst nämlich
nicht für umgangen weil die no alles weg
vielleicht ist schon geschlüpft und dann
ist weggelaufen
ich habe sich genommen wo ist das hin
keine ahnung vielleicht macht sich
selbständig oder beweise sind eigentlich
stiften bleibt dann da eigentlich kannte
auch nicht so schnell schlüpfen
da kennt man pino ist weg vielleicht
geht's dann die nun wirklich schnell an
der drache brit award zwei folgen und
dino
die nur dort das auch relativ lange ich
das beim singleplayer getestet ok ich
hab' den jedoch fortgesetzt
genau hier stand er da kann mit el kaida
nicht helfen und ein mann - wer weiß da
brauchst du die ganze doch sohn dino auf
vielleicht taucht er gleich wieder auf
bei den minis manchmal komisch manchmal
unsichtbar geld diesen zwar da aber
diesen unsichtbar ja das problem wie so
oft dass ich einfach mal weg und dann
siehst du irgendwas abgebaut wird und
man hat uns immer leute auch mano wie
blöd das ist kommt leider mal vor
aber egal ich aber ich war trotzdem
nicht bekannt
hast du ganz portal geguckt ich brauche
ich schon gesagt habe zwei stück im
inventar aber zwei stück brauche ich das
ist genial entweder du kommst du würde
ich komme zu dir
ich komme zu dsds hat dieses kleine haus
am wald richtig also noch es ist kein
wirkliches haus weil es nicht ordentlich
gemacht ist was soll ich dann vielleicht
doch mal leisten fertigmachen in folge
mehr forschung erzeugt ich komme ich
letzthin leicht mich zurückhalten wollte
ich bin christ und shuffle
sony ich bin noch weiter hinten weiter
weiter weil dieselbe richtung bei den
bäumen video da sind bei mir schon jede
menge provinz rom also magische bäumen
verschiedenen formen und farben und
diese riesen säule wo die ganzen sparks
stehen und hier sowieso die indianer so
zumindest sondern sind starten soll
welche lieder das stimmt schon mal hier
oder du fliegst einfach durch den
mammutbaum bald durch das alte dorf war
unterhalten bist bei real
wenn du in richtung des bildstocks
müssen wir da nichts nach unten schickte
man gegen fleißigste an spark fliegen
oder hier sorgt eine kleine hütte jetzt
gerade es und fluss und dem flussdelta
träume bleiben
der reeder da ich glaube ich das sehe
ich auch schon rum fa hergibt dann hat
man abheben wurde gefordert dass kann
ich gerne raus pupsen aber ich musste
zum kessel runter und dann meine
lieblings ein feuer machten sich ein
fehler da herausputzen
da fliegen zwei stück perfekt dankeschön
und will ich jetzt ganz kurz nach hause
machen wir dann die stadt was sie machen
wollte meine rpg kanonenkugeln und
danach würde ich sagen das wort die
folge schon entweder bei 15 minuten
gerade sind aber das möchte ich auch ein
start gehen wollen sie nicht schnell
schon wieder
ja diese 15 minuten gehen so schnell
vorbei ein megaprojekt damals als er
keine grenzen wenn du aufhören sonst
richtig auf ein ganzes ist ja alles was
in der augen ist und schiff man hat
vielleicht keine andere
okay das pocket ich muss man normale
machen ich brauche wolle wolle wolle
wolle
ich finds echt doof dass der onyx ich
einfach mal über mich baut er hat ich
denke ich auf meinen platz gehöre keine
ahnung warum
ja ich war von anfang an und jetzt kommt
er nicht einfach hin wollte auch
wahrscheinlich zu viel platz ich weiß es
nicht auch so rpg habe ich auch noch
eine kanonenkugel dafür wo soll ich denn
jetzt mal hin schießen pressehaus habe
nicht auf mein herr schwarz in der
nächsten folge ich will jetzt nicht in
dieser folge machen dann müsste die
nächste folge schauen damit ihr seht wie
es abläuft wenn ich eine rpg weg richtig
dann will ich auch schon sagen wir
beenden die folge jetzt mal weil wir
schon bei 60 minuten sind und wir wollen
ja nicht so krass überziehen
von daher 17 ist eigentlich noch okay
ich fange mal fliegt nur ganz kurz
personen sammeln um als ich in
schafswolle ein weil ich die gerne hätte
ich mache an meiner stelle schon mal
kurz kannst du die folge zu ende weil
ich die letzte folge schon gegen die 18
minuten landete
deswegen gehe ich schon mal ganz kurz
vorm sache wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lasst es mir mit einer bewertung
wissen und
schuh